jean bodin est un produit de l'office
national du film
il y entre en 1964 mais c'est en 75
qu'on le découvre avec le long métrage
julien martin photographe qu'il a co
écrit avec son ami le comédien marcel
sabourin
ce film présenté au festival de cannes
en 1977 vont le prix d'interprétation à
monique mercure
j'entendais des gens autour avez vous vu
alors à avion où la comédienne est
formidable à la simplicité et on entende
ndt qui s'exclamait qui voulait la
rencontrer pour fernand dansereau son
complice de toujours jean bodin est un
cinéaste sous-estimé d'un salon pour
regarder la télévision par hasard
pigeons en tant que filles de caleb
richard loyen ce genre venait pas de la
qualité de la mise en scène de
l'envergure de la mise en scène
au cinéma on se souvient du film
cordelia de being followed claude le
matou souvenirs intimes
jean bodin le touche-à-tout s'attaque
aussi aux séries télévisées
il réalise les filles de caleb en 1990 4
millions d'auditeurs regardait chacun
des épisodes toutes les semaines un
succès tous les quatre a cependant avoir
achevé une journée mais pour michel
coulombe une de ses grandes qualités
c'est qu'il était un découvreur de
talents c'est guillaume lemay thivierge
dans le matou c'est marina & run dans
les filles de caleb
c'est effectivement louise portal dans
cordelia donc quelqu'un qui a su trouver
et c'était son talent directeur
d'acteurs les bonnes personnes pour les
bons films les bonnes séries
il avait effectivement ce sens inné du
casting jean bodin est aussi connu pour
son caractère intempestif sur les
plateaux de tournage
guillaume lemay thivierge la vedette du
matou à l'époque en témoigne
si je pense aux techniciens c'est un
homme extrêmement dur si je parle aussi
je pense aux actes est un homme
extrêmement protecteurs c'est un homme
qui nous protégeait qui nous enseignait
qui étaient là pour s'assurer que que
les gens soient bien heureux sa
filmographie impressionnante lui a valu
l'ordre national du québec en 2016 et le
prix du gouverneur général pour les arts
et spectacles
l'année suivante en 2017 tout le
changement et l'évolution que j'ai pu
avoir sur 45 1
pour les plus jeunes générations qu'ils
ne connaissent pas c'est sans doute
l'occasion de le redécouvrir ici
catherine kovacs radio canada montréal